in the relationship which is thus
emerged it is only the character of
positive universality that is at first
observed and developed but a further
side presents itself which must also be
taken into consideration to wit if the
many determinant properties were
strictly indifferent to one another if
they were simply and solely self related
they would not be determinate for their
only determinate insofar as they
differentiate themselves from one
another and relate themselves to others
as to their opposites yeah as the
supposed to one another that cannot be
together in the simple unity of their
medium which is just as essential to
them as negation the differentiation of
the properties insofar as it is not an
indifferent differentiation but is
exclusive each property negating the
others thus falls outside of this simple
medium and the medium therefore is not
merely and also in indifferent unity but
is a one as well a unity which excludes
an other the one is the moment of
negation it is itself quite simply a
relation of self to self and it excludes
an other and it is that by which thing
would is determined as a thing negation
is inherent in a property as a
determinant 'no switch is immediately
one with the immediacy of being at
immediacy which though this unity with
through this unity with negation is
universality as a one however the
determinant is set free from this unity
with its opposite and exists in and for
itself
in Section 113 we
that Hagel finished up by talking about
what provided the thing hood to the
thing it was this also of the medium
that that's tying the properties
together in some sort of hole now in
Section 114 he's going to talk again
about universality and remind ourselves
to that each one of these properties can
be understood as the universality of
some sort you know a property like
sweetness or being cubical applies to
many things but each of these are a
sensuous universality and in a certain
respect an immediacy as well for the
procedure and here he's going to focus
exclusively on the object of perception
not on the perceiver that's going to run
through the this paragraph and the next
paragraph and then we're going to come
back to the perceiver in a moment and we
want to see how things are playing
themselves out we got ourselves to a
point where we realize that the medium
is is very important that's what allows
these different properties to exist as
themselves in relation to each other
because they can't exist as themselves
solely out there in space by themselves
independently notice two this is a
little bit of a digression but I think
it's worth worth pointing out that if we
think about traditional metaphysics
prior to Hegel if we use you know for
example Locke and Aristotle as examples
aerosol we'll talk about substance and
then the accidents or the product the
predicate sub that substance so man is
the substance white or red or black or
green or whatever you want rational we
could have things like good bad all
those are accidents all those are
predicates those are all properties
there I can shift in in in the sense
that we're talking about here
and what's really much more important is
the the substance or the subject the the
thing that that allows them to exist as
what they are for John Locke you know in
period we can't really know for most
substances what they are and themselves
all we can really know are the
properties which we predicate of them
and again those properties are things
that for the most part we take in by the
senses and we have words for them but
what's really allowing them to exist as
properties is the substance in which
they're in some sort of ways supposed to
in here and it gets a little bit more
complicated than that you know we have
primary and secondary properties I want
to get too far into those those details
but what's really interesting to see
here what you don't see in Locke and you
don't see an Aristotle and you don't see
it in a lot of previous thinkers is the
idea that it's these properties
themselves and their relations to each
other that make them what they are not
just there you know adherence or
inherent sin whatever the the subject or
substance happens to be but rather
something more at the level of their
relations with each other so how does
Hegel put this he says that if the many
determinate properties were strictly
indifferent to each other so in salt for
example we've been using that because
Hegel likes that example the whiteness
and the cubic allottee we'll call it
than having you know a cubical nature
and the tartness we could differentiate
them all out and say well you know you
get your whiteness here you got your
cubic ality here you've got your your
tartness or saltiness here and you just
put them together and this thing and
this also in this in German out and now
you get salt and that seems to be the
way that somebody like Locke for example
thinks about substances and thinks about
properties Hegel says no no these are
differentiating themselves I put
different here just because you know I
don't want to put differentiate because
it's a lot more right but they're
differentiating themselves from each
other I should probably also have time
this as well right these properties are
also interrelation in that way and it's
insofar as they they differentiate
themselves from an other and from an
other other that they are able to be
determinate they are able to be distinct
as as Hegel says they have a sort of
reality to them a sort of describe
ability you might say and so he says if
the determinant properties were
indifferent to each other if they are
simply and solely self related if you
could understand them just on their own
basis as universals then they would not
be determinate their only determinate
insofar as they differentiate from
themselves from one another they relate
one selves to their other as as what the
the translator has here as opposites the
the german is actually a little bit more
active when we think about opposites
that's a very passive way to think about
it
they are literally and Gagan Gazette's
which means put down gazettes
and gegen against each other
opposed to each other they are being you
know brought into relation as things
that don't that don't really go now they
are able to coexist in the same thing as
we've seen in previous paragraphs but
they have a kind of agency you might say
or a relief there they stand out against
each other that's what it means for them
to be and game Gazette's
in this sort of situation so he says as
are thus opposed to one another they
cannot be together in the simple unity
of their medium which is just as
essential to them as negation so what's
the medium the medium so far is this
also this this out this you've got this
and this and this and this the thing
allows there to be whiteness and cubic
ality and Turnus and you know graininess
or whatever else we want to say you know
about about salt dryness and this is not
able to support what's going on and down
here so we have an important transition
that's going to take place I just wanted
to make the arrow a little bit more the
state and we moved from the also to the
one the ayats he says the
differentiation of the properties
insofar as it's not an indifferent
differentiation but is exclusive each
one of these negating the others each
one of these pushing the others away
falls outside of this simple medium the
also can't keep it all there bound up
together we have to something that's got
a bit more you might say metaphysical
depth to it a little bit more solidity
and that's the one this is what gives
the the thinness to the thing Dean
Heights for the being about the thing so
he says it's not merely and also but a
one as well a unity which excludes
another salt is not shocked even though
they have whiteness and I guess dryness
in common they exclude others and they
are a relation to themselves they they
exclude others precisely by relating to
themselves now this sounds very abstract
what does Hegel talking about here he's
he's merely stressing that a thing is
what it is by being what it is being in
an active way in such a way as it
excludes other things it says I am NOT
that so it's not only a negation
happening down here at this level it's
also negation happening up here at you
might say the higher level again these
two interpenetrate each other so the
whiteness of the chalk may not be the
same thing as the whiteness of the salt
that's why we can differentiate
different whites right so he goes on and
he says the
was the moment of negation it's simply a
relation of self the self it excludes
another it's that by which thing good is
determined as a thing so we're giving
away from just thing good or thing Ness
ding height to an actual thing and when
we perceive which is what we're trying
to talk about here do we perceive thing
misses out there thing like and you know
entities or do we perceive actual things
that's where we want to go with this so
he goes on and he's bringing this to a
close here he says negation is inherent
in a property as a determinant Ness
which is immediately one with the
immediacy of being and immediacy which
through this unity with negation is
universality
that's how properties can be universals
we're seeing a new side now of what
would has been discussed previously so
he says as a one though the determinant
is set free from this unity with its
opposite and here he says something
really interesting
it exists in and for itself that's
whenever we see in and for itself we've
got things that have been brought to a
kind of close at least for the moment
now that we're gonna have a lot of
development going on after this but
whenever we see in and for itself we've
got kind of a galleon hiatus a little a
little step where we can say aha what
can we survey now that's what we want to
look at as we move into the next
paragraph
in these moments taken together the
thing as the truth of perception is
completed so far as it is necessary to
develop it here it is first an
indifferent passive universality the
also of the many properties or rather
matters second negation equally simple
or the one which excludes opposite
properties and third the many properties
themselves the relation of the first two
moments or negation as it relates to the
indifferent element and there and
expands into a host of differences the
point of singular individuality in the
medium of subsistence radiating forth
into plurality insofar as these
differences belong to the indifferent
medium they are themselves universal
they are related only to themselves and
do not affect one another but insofar as
they belong to the negative unity they
are at the same time exclusive of other
properties but they necessarily have
this relationship of opposition to
properties remote from there also the
sensuous universality or the immediate
unity of being and the negative is thus
a property only when the one and the
pure universality are developed from it
and differentiated from each other and
when the sensuous universality unites
them
it is this relation of the universality
as the pure essential moments which at
last completes the thing
section 115 is tracing out the same
movement that was just made in Section
114 looking at it from slightly
different vantage points and trying to
consolidate it so Hegel is going to talk
about three things that your text
actually puts as a B and C and we can
write them up here in a kind of chart
that represents a movement that's taking
place a movement in our own thinking in
the metaphysics of objects as well and I
want to point out here that when he's
talking about the thing as the truth of
perception in English I suppose to in
some other languages that might be where
we're using similar comments we can lose
a little bit of the play on words that's
going on or at least the residences that
are happening because Hegel is using the
same terms here you notice in the German
it's the vara the VAR name right var
name only misperception we've talked
about this previously it literally means
the taking of the truth of something and
so why is he so concerned with the truth
of the thing or the truth of perception
because that's what it is to perceive to
take truth to grasp the thing as what is
true as what is available is what is
there not as what is wrong what is false
or something like that we're going to
hit on that a little bit later so the
thing as the truth of perception there's
three moments in this development you
don't want to get too caught up with the
thesis antithesis synthesis thing that
people want a pigeonhole Hegel into here
because these are all actually tied
together these are three different
moments and this one the properties
turns out to include a whole plethora of
moments the one also does as well
because the one excludes another so
let's follow out this progression we
begin with the the also and he says that
it's an indifferent passive universality
what do we do what do we mean by this so
the thing itself is a universality
let me get away from the the salt
example for a little bit and just use
the piece of track again so we have a
thing as a passive universality this
piece of chalk this piece of track they
have you know the same properties are
almost the same size actually not
exactly the same but they may look the
same to you they're white they're cocky
and we shouldn't define things
circularly but you know what I mean that
there's a chalkiness to it they have a
kind of sound to them they're hard
they're dry all those properties are
bound together in this also that's the
medium these pieces of chalk are a
medium in which we find these properties
displaying themselves displaying
themselves and something true to the
perceiver there's a grasping of the
truth the truth of this is whiteness is
chalkiness is dryness so we have that
going on and like he says that's passive
it's the also of many properties or
rather manners that's a beginning point
and then we move to the one and when we
get to the one we have real things not
just thing Ness or thing likeness but
actual things this is a one this is not
the same one as this one even though
they're very similar these are different
from each other they exclude each other
and they don't just exclude each other
by the fact that I can't push them both
into the same place they exclude each
other in a metaphysical way so we've got
negation coming to the fore there we
have exclusion and not just at the level
of the the higher objects the things
that we can see as objects but also the
properties that's leading us here into
the properties so he says the many
properties themselves the relation of
the first two moments how are the
properties the relation of the also and
the one because those properties are
properties for both the also and for the
one which is the same thing just being
looked at in two different
by the perceiver that's a little bit of
what Hegel's not telling you that's kind
of behind the scenes there and so each
of these properties is going to be doing
something quite interesting we begin
with the properties as he says you know
starting out in the in different element
expanding to a host of differences a
plurality with a unity becoming a
plurality and he says in so far as these
differences belonging to the universal
medium themselves they are themselves
universal so each of these properties is
a universal as we've seen so like
whiteness is is a universe whiteness is
here in the truck whiteness is also here
in this chalk as well whiteness is in
the truck out on the floor whiteness is
all over the place
those blackness smells blue miss I
suppose so corduroy anise as your as
you're watching this right how denotes
corduroy makes that weird sound and in
fact of the Hegel
that's a little bit of a digression so
as we're moving from looking at the
properties from the perspective of the
also where each of the properties is
merely related to itself and is a
universal a sensuous Universal and we're
moving to the perspective of the one
where now we have exclusion now we have
something like activity going on he says
insofar as these differences are artists
in the universal medium they don't
affect each other but insofar as they
belong to this negative unity of the one
the negative unity that excludes the
other they are at the same time
exclusive of other properties but they
necessarily have this relationship of
opposition of properties remote from
their also what does that mean they have
this this they're differentiating from
each other we saw this
but the also was going to let them do
whatever they wanted to do pretty much
and it's pretty passive the properties
are also differentiating themselves from
the properties found in the other so
this chalk the whiteness of this truck
not only differentiates itself from the
dryness of the chalk this chalk it
differentiates itself from the dryness
of this truck
and the whiteness of this truck that's
part of what it means for this exclusion
to be going on and you know if we follow
this out further which Hegel's not doing
here this father is another one isn't it
so this entire thing is also contained
here and all of that is happening in
that direction as well with all the
properties involved there that's a lot
to think about anything a lot to think
about I think that's kind of a silly
thing to say anyway he goes on and he
says the sensuous universality or the
immediate unity of being in the negative
is thus a property only when the one and
the pure universality are developed from
it and differentiated from each other
and when the sensuous universality
unites them it's this which then at last
completes the thing so in a certain way
properties are not quite yet properties
when we're just dealing with this when
we're letting them be what they are you
know it we're going to certain so it's
more abstract with it
properties are properties as sensuous
universalities
light whiteness like dryness precisely
by differentiating themselves by
opposing themselves to other properties
and by doing that through the mediation
of the one by not being the one but at
the same time being something that is a
component of the one
this then is how the thing of perception
is constituted and consciousness is
determined as precipitant insofar as
this thing is its object it has only to
take it to confine itself to a purely
apprehension of it and what does this
yield it is the true if consciousness
itself did anything and taking what it
is given it would buy such adding or
subtraction alter the truth since the
object is the true and universal the
self identical while consciousness is
alterable and unn essential it can
happen that consciousness apprehends the
object incorrectly and deceives itself
the percipient is aware of the
possibility of deception for in the
universality which is the principle
other 'no sit self is immediately
present for him though present as what
is null and superseded his criterion of
truth is therefore self-identity and his
behavior consistent apprehending the
object as self identical since the same
at the same time diversity is explicitly
there for him it is a connection of the
diverse moments of his apprehension to
one another but if a dissimilarity makes
itself felt in the course of this
comparison then this is not an untruth
of the object for this is self identical
but an untruth in perceiving it
if you've been wondering well where is
the perceiving subject in all of this
we've been looking at the thing and its
properties and all this really
interesting stuff going on in section
116 we're bringing back the subject the
perceiving consciousness into the
equation but notice what's going to
happen I'm gonna sort of just spell it
out right at the start anything that's
wrong
anything that's untrue is going to fall
entirely on the side of and in the
responsibility of you might say
consciousness anything that's good real
it's all going to be on the side of the
object and when you see something like
that you should you should immediately
say that's probably not gonna last very
long but it one's going to last for this
paragraph so let's see how this plays
out for Hegel we've come to the point
where now we realize that the thing is
the true the true thing of perception
and perception is true when
consciousness as the subject is is
perceiving the thing it as it is it's
just perceiving the thing without any
sort of blockage or filtering without
any what he's going to call adding or
subtracting you were going to come right
back to that in just a moment but I want
to go through some of this this
terminology say says consciousness is
determined as percipient insofar as it
has the thing as its object it only has
to take it it only has to grab on to it
again we see that perceiving VAR naman
Varnum means to grab the truth to to
hold on to the truth to take the true to
oneself and so what's going to happen in
this is insofar as consciousness is
grasping the true that's that's there so
far as its replicating the true within
itself you might say it is getting
things right
what is it getting right well it's going
to be grasping the thing as a universal
so something that's intelligible
something that
it can make sense of something that it
can bring into language as we've seen
and it's grasping it as self identical
he says since the object of the is the
true and universal the self identical
while consciousness itself is alterable
and uh nacelle it can happen that
consciousness loses track of things and
ends up deceiving itself
why because consciousness is actually
going to be deceiving itself in a double
way here
it wants to grasp the thing or the true
in perception is self identical that
means that does it relate itself to
other Ness no it sort of dispels other
dis from itself so the thing becomes
something that should not be other than
what it is and here we're now in the
realm of a equals eight nothing but a
right Hegel is going to take us away
from that in a moment but he wants to
make this as stark as possible so he
says the the criterion of truth becomes
self identity and behavior good behavior
on the part of consciousness consists in
apprehending the object as self
identical the piece of chalk is what it
is and that's it nothing more insofar as
I add anything to it
insofar as I take anything away from it
over here now I'm changing the thing
what does that mean that means that what
I'm doing is incorrect I'm not getting
the thing as it is because I'm not
letting the thing be self identical I'm
trying to hold you know postulate or
pusher or project my own nonsense onto
it but I'm just an innocence of
consciousness I'm just the perceiver I'm
not I don't know the dignity of the
object right and this means that it's
possible for consciousness to cause its
own deception something that we ought to
think about as an aside is whether this
we'll process here this whole picture
that we've got isn't itself away the
consciousness sometimes deceives itself
in modern philosophy and in naive grasp
on perception in any case we're gonna
want to if we're good
consciousness is don't do any of this
all right just stick with this and then
we're gonna be a-okay we we grasp the
truth and as such we don't want to be
caught in deception if we are it's our
own fault
we're the ones who impose that upon
ourselves like you know Descartes says
for example in his meditations when I'm
deceived I can you know say that there's
some sort of evil deceiver out there but
that evil deceiver can't really deceive
me if I actually stick to what I know
and don't add or subtract anything he
doesn't use those words but that's
Hegel's terms so he goes on and he says
the precipitant is aware of the
possibility of deception and once you
open up the door to possibly being
deceived you know a rabbit hole that
turns out to be and he says since at the
same time diversity is explicitly there
for him it's a connection of diverse
moments of his apprehension to one
another if a dissimilarity makes itself
felt in the course of this comparison
then this is not an untruth of the
object no not on the side of the object
the object can be inert the object can
be passive the object can even be
eternal if there is some sort of
difference if there's some sort of
change if there's some sort of
immutability it must be on the side of
the subject the untruth lies over here
so he says an untruth in perceiving it
is this going to be a position that we
can continue to stick with well we're
going to see egill is going to move away
from this but we want to see very
clearly what this stance consistent so
to sum up where we've gotten to at this
point the thing is the true perception
insofar as it participates in truth
insofar as it's grasping truth
has to be consciousness letting the
object be exactly what it is be self
identical and insofar as there's
anything that's changing or fluctuating
or any sort of alterity
any sort of other Ness any sort of
opposition going on that's on the side
of consciousness and that's probably an
index of deception that consciousness is
carrying out for itself applying to
itself it's causing its own untruth